you hit your first million around the
age of 24 you started around 19
yeah yeah 24 was when i like banked
first mill after tax all right and
you're in toronto so you're a local guy
um haven't haven't had the uh pleasure
running into yet uh irl but um how did
you get started with um you know
self-care and
monetizing uh taking your shirt off i
suppose is the best way to to you know
summarize it
you know the the thing that kind of
state is that like
i had a passion for fitness at a really
really young age like literally 13 i was
like already obsessed with the idea of
working out building muscle doing
push-ups um lifting weights and and so
throughout my entire teenage years like
working out was my passion and something
i was really really obsessed with and i
would read all kinds of content
um and so that actually like helped me
wasn't just like oh i'm 18 or 19 now i
got into fitness last year and now i
want to monetize it um this is something
that was uh was that i was always always
very into and so at 19 years old
i i felt very disenfranchised from
university from going to school doing a
program for four years working up the
corporate ladder i wanted to kind of
build my own thing and the idea of
building a business around fitness like
was the dream i was like this is like i
love fitness this isn't even a job this
is what really really want to do
and uh
i started personal training um but i
just didn't it didn't see
personal like training clients every day
just did not was not fulfilling to me i
didn't see really like the big picture
there and i remember getting my first
mentor a guy named rusty moore
and and he
he was building a fitness blog that was
getting you know hundreds of thousands
of visits a month and he was an
affiliate marketer and he was actually
you know building a six-figure income um
with his blog and then that like that
really sparked my interest i was like i
could do this i could create content on
fitness and and you know and you know
build traffic build an email list and
then start to you know promote promote
different programs or build my own and
that's like at 19 that's why i started
kinobody and like i i never went back
from there why did why did fitness
fascinate you like why all the push-ups
and you know the working out and the
obsession with it
i i remember like growing up like kind
of watching movies uh with arnold
schwarzenegger sylvester stallone van
damme and i just i kind of saw these
characters that were strong and powerful
and i wanted that you know i think as a
kid i felt a little small and i wanted
like i just like in my
like in my blood i just wanted to be
strong and powerful i didn't want anyone
to mess with me so i think the initial
driver of fitness was more so i could
handle myself so i could protect myself
uh so i could defend myself so no one
could even bully bully me and it was
never neces it was never about
impressing girls the the driver was kind
of to
feel like that role model that i was
seeing in that movie did you get bullied
as a kid like did you feel
nothing crazy but just kind of a little
bit just you know just just just a
little bit and i just like i just
remember just the feeling of it just
never want to feel like that like i
think some people can get like bullied
and and they let like for me it's like
like i i have a chip on my shoulder with
that so like i like like a little a
little boy i'm like [ __ ] i'm going to
go train i'm going to do whatever i have
to do i don't want to be in that
position yeah i i think fortunate was
what uh you know
flipped the switch for me when i saw him
in uh conan i was like whoa like that's
that's pretty impressive right it's like
no homo was just like straight up how
can somebody look like that and
everybody else looks like that and this
guy's able to command that level of
presence
um i remember when i was
it was probably around the same age as
you and i was i was like a little bit of
a well i wasn't a little bit i was
actually a really scrawny kid because i
think around 12 or 13 i was about six
foot six foot one and i was maybe like
130 pounds and my dad gave me this um
mail order
basically a pamphlet from when he got it
when when he was in the royal air force
and it was done by this guy called
charles atlas i don't know if you know
yeah about that program
yeah no charles he was one of the like
early kind of fitness figures and yeah
like one of the originals right yeah
like the og and it's like you know it
was a program called dynamic tensions
and it was like you know push-ups and
chin-ups and you'd you know if you
wanted to build your chest you'd like
you know put your hands in like this or
if you wanted to build your biceps you'd
go like this right and do like a a curl
and it was a really interesting program
but it was just like i just went all in
with it too man it was it was um fitness
has always fascinated me like one of the
reasons why i follow greg guys is um i
think i came across your stuff maybe
like four or five years ago
and i saw this guy that was younger than
me with a with a really good physique
that was out there doing the work
getting really good reach and views on
youtube and instagram um and then he
started putting out these programs and
always found like the stuff that you
were putting out was
entertaining too like it wasn't just uh
you know educational there was a level
of like there's a couple of produced
videos that you did uh uh bruce wayne
won there was another one with you know
like american psycho i think yeah right
um really really good stuff like in fact
if you search for greg's name on google
it like
you actually come up as a filmmaker
yeah yeah
i did a little uh i did a little uh
executive producing and in a film or two
and so like i got on imdb and all that
stuff um but nothing i haven't done
anything like anything like i you know
big there yet
so a lot of guys look at dudes like you
and they're like oh he's an overnight
success he got lucky or they'll chalk it
you know chalk it up as um well you know
he inherited all of his money from his
dad because i know that your dad passed
when you were younger and he had a real
estate portfolio you didn't really have
an interest in real estate from what i
understood and
actually one of the things i wanted to
ask ask you about because there was a
note somewhere that i uh saw that you
went to university and you basically
dropped out because you saw the
marketing strategies that they were
teaching you was garbage or not useful
in the real world can you talk about
that a little bit
yeah yeah i mean i was on the fence
about going to university to begin with
i wasn't sure if it was even what i
wanted to do i i went kind of i got
sucked up into the moment um with all my
friends applying and all that and i went
to school and
and uh
i just kind of remember sitting in class
and just trying to like just trying to
figure out the roi like i'm sitting in
class and i would say
or 15 of of the time like okay maybe
there's utility to this
and then
80 like at least 80 i was like this is
not gonna help me this is not gonna
serve me in life this is not gonna help
me build a business make money become
successful and so i'm just like why am i
pouring in um four years of my life for
something that's not directly gonna help
get me to my goal and i you know i
remember one of the computer classes
that we're in we're learning this out
like outdated website development that
that was pretty much obsolete at the
time and i'm like this is
this is so dumb
like this is like this is a complete
waste of time and i'm in class i'm
looking in the auditorium okay at
university you got 150 people in an
auditorium everyone's coughing
the coffin like every three seconds and
i have like misophonia that stuff will
annoy me so i'm listening to all these
people are sick they're coughing they're
drinking all the time they're playing
farmville on the computer and i'm like
is this where i'm gonna learn to become
a multi-millionaire and i'm like this is
garbage and uh
and then i pretty much checked out for
the rest of the year and just kind of
just kind of did my own sort of
self-study and kind of went to went
through the motions and and kind of just
kind of got the the different gears kind
of moving
and um i think a lot of people get swept
up an idea that they have to go to
school even though it's kind of in vogue
to tell you you don't have to get go to
school they just can't handle the
pressure of their friends or family or
peers basically kind of tell them hey
you need that degree for me it's like
man life is short we have one life i am
not in a million years gonna give away
four years of my life just to appease
someone close to me no i'm going to do
what i want to do and uh you know i
always had that self belief that was
kind of built and sharpened from
training that hey if i want something
and if i set a goal and i'm willing to
work for it
i will achieve that goal it might not be
easy it might not happen in one straight
shot but i will figure it out and i will
get what i want and and that sort of
self-belief you want like you need to
have um if you're gonna start a business
or kind of go against the grain
you must have got some heat from family
for dropping out of university how did
that go down
um yeah i got i got
i definitely got some heat for the first
couple years
um
and
you know it it
it was it was uh you know it was kind of
i think like the idea kind of what i put
out i was like hey look i'm gonna i'm
gonna take a year or two to figure this
out and you know like i can always go
back to school and i knew and like i
knew my head i'm not gonna go back to
school but yeah there was a lot of flack
from friends from family from my family
friends saying like you're making a
colossal mistake you know everyone
thinks they can go and start a online
business and and make money it's it's
you know it's not gonna happen or you
know you're gonna end up being a
personal trainer and you you can't you
came from this
very very successful family you're not
gonna you're not gonna be satisfied on a
personal training salary and like deep
down like i want this is my life i want
to do what fulfills me we're going to
spend literally
60 70 of our life in our career and our
job so if you don't like it you're
throwing your life away and um
and i didn't even set out like my goal
when i got into the fitness online stuff
my goal was
i didn't care to like necessarily make
tons and tons of money i just wanted to
do what i loved and have freedom you
know freedom to kind of work where i
want um freedom to to to run my business
how i want and my initial goal was
basically you know what by the time my
friends graduate so basically in four
three four years i want to be making six
figures a year online for my business
and like that way you know these my all
my peers they're graduating school
they're having to look for jobs a lot of
times you probably know this like how
many people graduate from university and
they're working a job they could have
worked without without that degree
making my coffee at starbucks most of
the time yeah so i was like you know
what they're going to be running around
trying to find jobs and i'm going to be
making six figures for my online
business and i set that goal um and and
it happened and and again it took a long
long time for my fam for my family to
kind of give me that green light of
approval of what i was doing like i
think i had to have i think i had to be
making millions of dollars and have like
10 people working for me for them to
finally get it um but but at first
they're like oh this is just a short
term kind of fad or wait how are you
making money i don't understand like
like what is this
my mom had to have literally her like
family friends and lawyer and be like
wow what gregory's doing is so
impressive for her to even like be like
oh it is impressive so like it you know
it it definitely it definitely took a
while um but you know
it's uh it's it's kind of that the thing
is is that like
if if if you're actually meant to do it
you don't care you don't mind the flack
like if a little bit of your if your
family being upset and and telling you
no like like you want that you need that
pressure going against you because if
you can't handle that you're not going
to handle anything else
and i think in life it's good to have
kind of that opposing pressure because
it definitely like it like it it
it it makes you kind of like if if
everyone just tells you hey building a
business is easy and yes you're going to
start this online business and you're
going to make six figures in four years
and everything's going to go smooth like
if everyone's telling you that like then
you're going to have like you're gonna
expect it to go smooth and when things
get tough you're just gonna give up like
you need people tell you hey this is
really hard it's not gonna work out like
you you know so i actually like respect
that sort of pressure
you